olá bom dia é hoje vou contar pra vocês
é três conceitos de arte marcial
salvar a nossa vida é as artes marciais
pra todo mundo deve conhecer ela data
assim mais cinco mil anos atrás
específico assim do conforto então ela
tem uma história muito rica assim por
trás que sabe que é o nosso dia a dia e
ela o maior foco é trazer assim a paz
o espírito que as pessoas geralmente
quando as pessoas olham elas acham que
vai só aprender a socar chutar e que é
uma coisa violenta e pelo contrário nem
artes marciais
ele é um caminho de vida é um caminho
que se percorre o ano inteiro a sua vida
inteira e não tem fim é infinito então
as artes marciais nada mais é que uma
busca pelo espírito uma busca pelo seu
prazer é uma busca pela sua vida sua
vivacidade
então é isso que ela vai mostrar baseado
nisso eu gostaria de partilhar com vocês
a minha experiência
baseado nesse conceito e hoje nós vamos
ver assim o primeiro conceito de artes
marciais que serve pra nossa vida e em
jean e xandão nada mas é assim que o seu
olhar determinado ou seja o seu foco à
sua poder de concentração como ali na
foto coloquei lustrei com dois
personagens muito conhecidos é um da
esquerda aqui de vocês doni que muitas
vezes pode não conhecer e eu meio que de
todo lado que dispensa comentários e
quebras ele né
todo mundo pode não conhecer artes
marciais mas se falarmos luta não vai
dar um gritinho né e vai todo mundo já
conhece o que é então é muito fácil
assim de delirar então e em chã ele é um
olhar determinado a gente pode fazer com
um olhar determinado onde é nossos olhos
e chão algo divino algo espiritual algo
como um poder de determinação foco um
controle ou tudo que está envolvido com
a sua emoção isso é chan
esse olhar determinado ele pode ser
traduzido assim para o nosso conceito de
artista marcial
quando você entra no ringue ou quando
você entra em uma plataforma para uma
competição quando você entra pra só
fazer uma performance não só a luta em
si
você precisa estar com esse olhar muito
focado ou seja você trabalha o seu poder
de concentração você trabalha seu poder
determinação
e principalmente o seu foco você tem
sempre direcionar sempre tem que olhar
por mais que você esteja com nervoso mas
se até com receio mas os seus olhos têm
que transmitir muita sua essência aquilo
que é a sua verdade ali então é uma
parte muito fundamental extremamente
importância e vou contar uma história
assim bem curtinha pra vocês é no
passado quando eu comecei a praticar
artes marciais
eu fui fazer uma uma primeira luta na
sua primeira competição de luta eu
entrei no ringue assim olhando na final
adversário tremendo assim nossa com um
anda se com a mão até a subida tremendo
de nervoso vai poder encarar alguém pela
primeira vez lá numa experiência e
quando eu subir no ringue que olhei foi
nossa ele está mais preparado é mais
forte é mais isso é toda foi nossa
não espere aí né eu também entrei eu
também estou preparado então porque é
que só ele vai estar preparado porque só
ele está com essa força toda então falei
para mim mesmo nossa então eu preciso
treinar meu em cena é preciso treinar
meu foco e determinação e principalmente
meu olhar
então o que eu fiz eu coloquei interno
para mim assim meu olhar determinado
encarei a situação de frente olhei lá
para o meu adversário falei
a série se alguém que vai comendo vai
ser voltar tremendo por dentro mas se a
gente vai com medo vai ser ele e vou
transmitir que esse olhar seja passando
para ele a energia que ele fique com
mais medo que eu naquele dia e até o fim
é assim que eu subi para o ringue e
lógica se a primeira luta como não podia
ser
não é lógico é também apanhei muito caí
mas e apanhei com dignidade apanhei coco
com maestria a foi assim com conca ídolo
chamas sem medo nenhum sem remorso
nenhum e meu olhar estava inteiro com
planetário podia estar no chão caindo
mas eu estava olhando com a cara séria
pra ele que até ele ficou com medo assim
de lá levantar a mão pra poder me ajudar
mas enfim o que eu quero dizer com isso
né
traduzindo o nosso meio de vida o em chã
nada mais é assim que você encarar de
frente uma situação de vida encarar de
frente assim qualquer situação que vocês
passem se você vai entrar por exemplo
uma entrevista de emprego a sua primeira
vez nessa entrevista vai estar nervoso
vai tá tenso vai estar com inúmeras
coisas na cabeça pensando assim nossa
como eu vou agradar como que eu vou
falar com essa pessoa como eu vou falar
com alguém que pode ser meu chefe como
que eu vou falar com alguém que pode me
dar trabalho a qualquer momento eu não
posso saber fazer então como que eu vou
encarar isso então e em chã e é uma
ferramenta para você transmitir
trabalhar esse poder de concentração
imagina você entrar numa entrevista de
emprego e você tá assim olhando para
baixo tá meio perdido faz pergunta você
falou se não é é isso aí você fica assim
sem encarar as pessoas
então isso hoje em dia é é quase
impossível separar entrevista de emprego
ou qualquer que seja o ambiente você não
encarar de frente uma pessoa você não
encarar com a sua vida com a sua
essência e transmite essa emoção para
pessoa
por mais que você tem ali sendo julgado
com vários olhares mas você tem que
transmitir algo pra frente você tem que
permitir que você está preparado você
tem que admitir que seu foco é
importante transmitir que você está
determinado para aquela condição de
entrevista de emprego ou qualquer que
seja a situação então você tem que estar
preparado e onde nós preparamos isso
interiormente então o seu olhar é uma
ferramenta importantíssima para você
fazer isso mesmo que seja por um pequeno
assim você vai lidar com a sua família
você vai lidar com sua esposa namorada
ou namorado qualquer que seja até com o
seu cãozinho né você precisa transmitir
isso olhar as pessoas elas pegam isso
com o olhar
se você fala pra alguém você precisa ver
a pessoa você precisa enxergar a pessoa
não é só simplesmente olhar
oi tudo bem acabou de sair você precisa
enxergar mais além disso então a
ferramenta assim da arte marcial é muito
em cima disso você precisa enxergar
realmente e transmitir algo para as
pessoas
você precisa que isso entre no coração
da pessoa ainda mais hoje em dia que
você entra em qualquer ambiente ainda
mais por tecnologia e inovações
muita coisa está se perdendo esse
contato né hoje você ainda tem um
elevador ea pessoa nem olha pra você
olha para baixo não fala bom dia sai
correndo e torce pra no dia seguinte
pegar levado um segundo antes de você
para poder encontrar ninguém na rua
enquanto ninguém na calçada não quer
assim se isolar do mundo
então essa ferramenta volta a dizer
assim é muito importante em nosso
convívio assim ser humano você pode
encarar alguém frente olhar pela olho no
olho e falar nossa eu tô aqui você
também está aí nós fazemos parte desse
mundo então passar uma ferramenta assim
fundamental importância para nós
artistas marciais e pelo nosso convívio
como ser humano eu espero assim que nós
podemos trabalhar muito essa essa inicia
hoje aqui nessa palestra tá bom então
baseado nisso assim as artes marciais
têm vários conceitos o primeiro deles
chance de olhar pra olhar do bruce lee
naquela tela só alijada para transmitir
seu real poder que ele tem o real poder
que está transmitindo uma imagem parada
pra nós aqui na tela eu não consigo
olhar a lhe falar nossa coitadinho não é
nossa ele está muito tranqüilo ali nossa
não quer transmitir nada olhar dele já
mostra que é algo muito grande ele está
por trás daquilo ali não só de uma luta
não só de uma modalidade de arte marcial
mas sim ele está a vida dele jogo é algo
assim que ele acredita que ele pratica
que ele faz mas assim além de tudo isso
é a vida dele que está em jogo é algo
que ele precisa transmitir às pessoas
como qualquer trabalho de vocês se você
vai fazer seu trabalho muito bem ser
transmitir essa essência pessoa você não
vai simplesmente fazer por fazer um
trabalho e ficar com isso você vai ter
que transmitir então volto a dizer a sua
primeira ferramenta pra isso é o seu
olhar real é a sua essência é real
então esse é um fundamento importante
pra nós todos trabalhar esse conceito
com muito afinco e partindo desse
princípio vou encarar o segundo conceito
de artes marciais
segundo o conceito ele chama tingly de
em les dele nada mais é que uma saudação
ou seja uma saudação que você faça pra
alguém um comprimento que você faça para
alguém ou seja um respeito que você
tenha uma outra pessoa
esse é um dos primeiros importantes
conceitos o primeiro
importante técnica que nós aprendemos
nas artes marciais
quando nós entramos em uma academia uma
escola ou qualquer que seja o ambiente
de uma a escola de artes marciais
todo mundo quer aprender a fazer socorro
fazer chute pulos né que viu em filmes e
principalmente né se defender então todo
mundo gosta de fazer
tem que ter uma defesa porque o mundo lá
fora está meio complicado entanto não
quer se defender mas pelo contrário
assim quando você entra em um ambiente
uma escola de artes marciais quando você
entra em uma academia de artes marciais
uma sala você tem quase um ritual para
cumprir
então você não vai aprender de cara
fazer soco você vai aprender a fazer
chutes você não vai aprender a
simplesmente autodefesa
o primeiro fundamento importante que nós
vamos aprender quando entra é respeito
respeito seja para você entrar até numa
sala de treino você precisa fazer uma
saudação você precisa complementar você
precisa ter um respeito embutido ali não
é simplesmente você pisa entra e vai
fazer seu treino pisar fora e saem vai
embora
não é isso as artes marciais ea nossa
vida é muito maior que isso
então nós vamos ter muito respeito com
tudo então essa é a primeira ferramenta
nas artes marciais
nós trabalhamos muito assim você
simplesmente entra aprendi uma saudação
aprendi com respeito e depois disso você
começa a praticar depois disso então
aqui é o segundo passo
depois que você começa a desenvolver o
que você está proposto que a sua vida
seja qual que ser qualquer que seja o
seu objetivo da saúde seja se é um bom
atleta um bom praticante primeira coisa
tem que ter respeito
então esse símbolo de aperto de mão é o
que nós usamos aqui no ocidente
geralmente né a gente vai lá aperto de
mão complementa
só nesse gesto ele está sendo embutido
muitas coisas muitas coisas você não
simplesmente não vai pra pessoa aperta a
mão sem o olhar se aperta lá sair de
qualquer jeito e pronto acabou e vira já
sai falando mal de todo mundo e onde
quem tem esse respeito porque aqui tem
um aperto de mão porque você
simplesmente dá um pouquinho da pessoa
e ela doou pra você e você simplesmente
esqueceu quem tirou esse respeito
então essa é uma funda um a ferramenta
importante que é o primeiro nosso dia
quem aprende quando entra numa escola de
artes marciais
aprendi a ter respeito pelas pessoas
hoje em dia assim com o mundo como está
na tecnologia toda evolução como falei
anteriormente é nós entramos assim no
ambiente às vezes você nem dá bom dia às
vezes nem dá boa tarde sai com todo o
caso teve ali na esquina já saí correndo
pra não te cumprimentar eu sair com tudo
né
então hoje em dia uma ferramentas
importantíssimas
então já que você vai fazer isso com
alguém vai cumprimentá lá vai
reverenciar baixar a cabeça qualquer que
seja o seu conceito de saudação
você precisa transmitir também o que o
seu amor por aquilo a sua vontade por
aquilo você não simplesmente não oferece
a sua mão pra alguém e pronto acabou né
você oferece sempre com respeito sempre
você quer sentir o que é valorizado e na
nossa vida não é não é o contrário disso
quando você está com a sua família
quando você está no ambiente do seu
trabalho
quando você está em qualquer situação e
até pesquisas mostram isso o que as
pessoas mais querem na vida sentir se
valorizada que eu cheguei pra você
valoriza seu trabalho ela quer que a sua
família olha pra você valoriza o seu
esforço na sua casa é os seus pais até
que vocês valorizou o esforço na
faculdade porque está sendo investido
dinheiro tempo um monte de coisa então o
mínimo que ele espera o respeito em cima
disso lote com o passar do tempo nós
vamos entendendo realmente o que
significa isso né
a gente vai crescendo vai desenvolver e
vai cada vez trabalhando mais esse
conceito cada vez entendo melhor como
funciona e botânico na nossa vida então
o respeito é uma ferramenta assim de
fundamental importância para a nossa
saúde do dia a dia então se você vai
realmente procurar um emprego vai sair
daqui vai fazer medicina vai fazer
advocacia vai fazer qualquer que seja o
seu trabalho qualquer que seja a sua
vontade
precisa principalmente de respeito com
as pessoas têm respeito com seu ambiente
de respeito com a sua família ter
respeito com tudo que está ao nosso
redor
o nosso mundo ele só transforma se eu
consegui
se nós conseguirmos passar esse respeito
adiante as gerações que vêm à nossa
volta depois conseguir transmitir sobre
as pessoas mas não se transmitir
simplesmente transmitir somente nós
estamos assim tem uma verdade nisso nós
vamos colocar isso pra frente com
verdade mesmo com o seu sentimento
então voltando à la na historinha nada
competição é é quando a apanhei com
dignidade e volto a dizer tá não foi só
uma apanha sozinho é quando você levanta
e acaba mesmo assim um combate você tem
respeito com outra pessoa vocês levanta
termina cumprimenta ela sai por mais que
ela seja o adversário naquele momento
mas na vida ela não é só o adversário
o adversário no momento x passou daquilo
ela é ser humano ela precisa de respeito
tanto quanto qualquer um tanto quanto
todos aqui e no ambiente de trabalho é o
mesmo sentido mesmo sentido à vida ela
tem que ser agressiva nos negócios e
chinatown tempo inteiro em competição
seja no seu trabalho por um salário
melhor por um cargo melhor
qualquer que seja a sua situação que
você quer transmitir o que você almeja
alcançar o seu objetivo
você precisa ter um pouco de
agressividade mas isso não quer dizer
que você não possa ter respeito pelas
pessoas
isso não quer dizer que você tem que
passar por cima a qualquer custo das
pessoas
você consegue alcançar o seu objetivo
mas simplesmente tendo o respeito tendo
dini e o terceiro conceito nós vamos ver
hoje
não não tão um diferente dos demais
chamar-lhe ró lhe ross significa seja
flexível simplesmente seja flexível
aqui nós temos assim um conceito de uma
água e uma garrafa e tem uma fase assim
uma frase famosa de bruce lina onde você
coloca água e um copo
o que acontece agora ela se molda no
copo
se eu tiro a água do copo e põe uma água
e uma garrafa que ela acontece ela se
moda uma garrafa se coloque um bule ela
se move um golo
então a água ela vai ficando flexível
ela vai se moldando conforme aquele
ambiente
mas ela também pode ser destruir o
como você vê assim as águas batendo numa
rocha numa maré ela vai bater ao longo
dos anos passando tudo quando vê a rocha
vai ficando deteriorada vai acabando vai
destruindo e terminou então o que a água
quer dizer assim com isso né
ela pode ser algo que pode fluir pode
ser algo que pode destruir como assim a
nossa vida
então o ser flexível aqui
quando a gente entra num conceito também
demais na escola de artes marciais
eu quero fazer um movimento eu quero
fazer simplesmente um soco e eu vou
tencionar tudo e dá um soco com força e
também sua primeira coisa que eu quero
aprender com a nossa eu tenho muita
força eu sei fazer um soco eu sei fazer
um chute eu vou botar toda a minha força
lá e fazer o socorro voltar toda a minha
força fazer um chute
então isso eu sei que é que eu tenho eu
sei que eu já tenho esse motivo eu vou
fazer qualquer que seja a idade eu já
chego lá não tento fazer meu golpe tem
que fazer com maestria mas botar a maior
força possível
certo não é pelo contrário as artes
marciais é ensinar o que a nós somos
flexíveis flexíveis
então assim se eu vou fazer qualquer que
seja o movimento
eu não preciso embutir toda a força do
movimento eu preciso saber o meu
conceito técnico do movimento quer saber
onde está a minha força onde está a
minha energia onde está minha potência
de movimento para poder usar então eu
vou dar um soco e não vou fazer ele com
toda força vou relaxar o máximo que deve
chegar aqui no finalzinho túnel coloca
força porque eu só preciso desse curto
espaço para atingir um golpe não tinha
essa força vem com tudo daqui de trás
travado endurecido e jogar aí eu saio
com os benefícios de artes marciais né
sai o que o dolorido ombro perna braço e
aí eu cheguei à minha casa e fala que a
mãe nossa mãe hoje aprendi lá nas artes
marciais nossa ganhei muitos benefícios
quais
isso ao todo o ocorrido meu ombro e no
braço
minha perna hamas que você pegar os
hockey fiz chute mas botei toda força
coloquei mas e o benefício disso eu vou
fazer a longo prazo e ficar quebrado e
ficar tão dolorido e à minha saúde é até
onde vai
então as artes marciais pelo contrário
nós vamos ter o que flexibilidade nós
estamos sendo flexíveis
nós precisamos assim saber que o golpe
está ali mas sabemos da nossa energia
para aquele movimento
sabemos da nossa energia para cada golpe
e pra nossa vida a gente pode passar o
mesmo paralelo
quando você conversa com alguém que ele
tem uma opinião diferente da sua e nem
hoje o mundo agora tá tá mais fácil de
chegar você fala com alguém tem uma
opinião diferente da sua e não aceita
sua opinião ele não tá flexível ele você
fala já retruca ir e te agride quase
chega brigar porque a sua opinião
diferente da dele
por que você não falou igualzinho ele ou
por que você não partilha da mesma
opinião que ele teve
e onde entra a nossa flexibilidade em
volta disso
onde que entrara isso né foi eu tenho
quantas milhões de pessoas no mundo eu
não vou ser igual não vou ter a mesma
opinião então eu preciso respeitar a
outra pessoa precisa ser flexível com
outra pessoa então não posso
simplesmente chega lá botar minha
opinião e acha que a pessoa vai cumprir
isso que estou falando
então assim eu preciso eu preciso que
isso passe passe pra diante
então quer dizer assim a gente nós
podemos ser flexíveis porém nós não não
não não precisamos ser rígido com as
pessoas nós podemos ser maleável com as
pessoas
então hoje o que queria passar estes
conceitos e apenas quem refletir juntos
têm respeito pelas pessoas
vamos ser flexíveis com as pessoas e por
fim seja como a água seja molde com as
pessoas e faça pelo menos a gente pensar
e refletir juntos para que o mundo seja
melhor daqui pra frente
muito obrigado
inspirado